You want me to restate the question?
Well, the question is, "What is the political
establishment doing in the run up to Super
Tuesday?"
I think the obvious answer is praying.
One of the things that has been highlighted
by this election season, and particularly
the success of Donald Trump, is how weak the
establishment is.
How you seen that?
On the Democratic side as well.
Bernie Sanders isn't even a Democrat.
Donald Trump, by a lot of measures, is a more
loyal Democrat than Bernie Sanders is.
So there's that burning, yearning desire to
find a candidate that the "establishment"
can rally around as an alternative to Donald
Trump.
And the fighting that we've been seeing on
the Republican side, where bizarrely for most
of this primary season the establishment candidates
have all been attacking each other rather
than attacking Donald Trump, that will sort
of no longer be tenable, but coming into Super
Tuesday, everyone's pitch is gonna be, "I'm
the guy who can take down Trump," and who
that guy is I have no clue whatsoever.